it's the picture that sums up all the
madness in our country one of the
illegals who wailed on two NYPD officers
in Times Square and got no bail flipping
not one but two birds as he walked out
of court the 22-year-old illegal giving
two middle fingers to the country that
welcomed him in he's one of the seven
migrants arrested for the cop beat down
so let me get this straight he strolls
across the border was given Free Shelter
beat up cops and suffered no
consequences and this is how he thanks
us and his other cop eting buddies were
just as gracious seen blowing kisses and
smiling after they left court and there
was another delightful bird
sighting but it looks like liberal
leaders are done being embarrassed by
The Ungrateful illegals New York
Governor Kathy hokel and New York city
mayor Eric Adams are ready to send these
bird flipping migrants South for the
winner in response to police searching
for additional suspects in the Time
Square attack on Polie get them all and
send them
back you don't touch our police officers
you don't touch anybody those who are
breaking our laws uh we need to
reexamine uh the laws that don't allow
us uh to deport them but some have
already Flo in the cope New York Post
reporting police believe four of the
criminals have already hopped on a bus
to California they allegedly gave fake
names to a nonprofit that helps migrants
get out of the
city uh judge Janine if you were
representing one of these illegals would
you recommend the double
bird well let me tell you this if I were
representing them uh it would be in my
next life be a cold day let me let me
just put it this way you're talking
about flipping the bird the middle
finger the mayor the da the president
and the governor are all flipping us the
middle finger and I'll tell you why the
first problem is Alvin brag Alvin brag
didn't ask for any bail these are class
SE violent felonies you can get bail he
didn't ask for bail I want to know why
number two why didn't Alvin brg put this
case in the grand jury so they could
have been arraigned in Superior Court
and had bail set and then they wouldn't
have gone to California that's where Al
Alvin brag screwed up then you got
governor hokel governor hokel says yeah
now it's a good idea after a reporter
asked her what I want to hear from the
governor is this I'm putting it in my
Governor's legislative package and I
want the legislator to legisl to vote on
deportation okay the mayor is a former
cop I don't want to hear him just
talking and talking what he's got to do
is call the da and say what are you
doing and why are you not asking for
bail and in addition to that the mayor
should be headlining an effort to make
the assault of a police officer an
offense for which they can call an ice
because New York is a sanctuary City you
can only call in ice on certain crimes
if the mayor really meant what he's
saying he could say today I want the
council to change and include assault on
a police officer that's a fix there now
the the problem with Joe Biden and is
giving us the middle finger is the
border and Texas has just proved it
since the end of January Texas because
of its border and because of what
they're doing to prevent them from
coming in they've got a huge drop in
Immigration and it's all coming in now
through Arizona and California and let
me say one more thing about this
these I don't even want to call them
people cuz they're not people these
people come here and they say they want
Asylum and we suckers believe it they
don't respect authority they take
authority down one of the other ones we
didn't know about yesterday was charged
with resisting arrest he pushed a cop
last time a cop arrested him in addition
to their beating down the arrest so I'm
sick and tired of hearing this nonsense
they traveled 3,000 miles through the
Darian Gap it's one of the most
dangerous places in the world cuz they
want to be part of the American dream
bull Boney they don't want to be part of
the American dream they don't want to
swear Allegiance they don't show up for
their Asylum hearing and 85% of them who
do don't get Asylum Richard why won't
Democrats Deport people like this I
think they're trying to mean they're
trying to listen I'm going to tell you
why I mean look I agree with everything
the judge said again we agree Hey listen
uh but here's what we know to be true if
you talk to the folks in in Senator
Christ Kristen Cinema's office which she
she briefed the press a couple days ago
there's a border bill that the Democrats
and Republicans are working to get done
that would secure the Border it would
end folks who cross if you cross
illegally you would go immediately to
jail and then you would be immediately
deported it would it would it would it
would allow the federal government to
buy planes to do faster deportations
right it would hire more border
Personnel it would increase the amount
of immigration judges so right now if
somebody seeking asylum in this country
and they get a notice to go to court
they don't see a judge until
2027 this bill would speed that up sadly
given all of that we have folks in the
in the in the house that say they're
going to vote no on this just
because one who got rid
of got rid of remain in Mexico to be
Mexico you got to give me that but but
but the judge but judge also last week
in South Carolina the president said
let's secure this border and let's pass
this bill right now he doesn't need
Congress he can do it himself Richard
why not have Congress do
they don't need to he can shut it down
buy morees it judges already to hire
more border patrol shut it down whenever
he wants I love that that photo can we
put that up there again the one that we
just had that is a great photo and I
love that we blurred the finger uh I
think we can handle it you know it's not
like we're trying to protect the
identity of his middle finger it's not
like his finger's under age I mean it's
true it's like I think I think it's
important to see
the reality of this situation right if a
picture's worth a th words that one is
worth 10 million and it's an old adage
in television if you want to see the
truth turn the sound off I do that with
Jesse's show when you take away all the
ranting and the raving and the politics
and the grandstanding and the shrieking
you have One Singular photo that tells
you everything about the basic nature of
human behavior that is they dis
disrespect you because they can they
disrespect you because you're weak what
you're seeing right there is how far
we've gone down this this path there's
no disincentives there's no consequences
land it's the land of the free for
criminals the American dream is America
Reed when these people come here and I
do think you know the busting of the
migrants the sanctuary cities was a
brilliant move the next step is
transporting any illegal with a record
to the neighborhood of the elites who
support these policies because something
tells me these migrants won't be
trimming your Hedges or doing your
dishes Dana well one thing about these
guys that escaped I think it was
actually it will turn out to be five of
them and they Ed false IDs to get on the
buses so there's another crime and also
they said they're going to California
anyone believe they're going to make it
all the way to California so now they're
going to be in some other place welcome
to Middle America and now they've got a
problem hopefully they will be too dumb
to get off in a sanctuary state or
Sanctuary City and they could call ICE
where they could be deported unless you
think that Joe Biden is the only problem
on the border today 150 house Democrats
voted against deporting illegal
immigrants who commit
DUIs so they voted against 150 Democrats
voted against that today now maybe
there's something else in the bill Etc
but over and over Republicans are
putting them on record as to what they
want and what they believe okay and if
we're going to put anything on record my
is pretty good with the volume down
watch it anyway you still get the rating
that's right yeah cuz you look great up
next thank you Judge Joe Biden's green
Jihad gets Dumber the Biden
Administration is now classifying
Martha's Vineyard as lowincome to pump
up his pricey electric vehicle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else